>>> PEOPLE HAVE FLED OVER FEARS
OF ANOTHER VOLCANIC ERUPTION
GROW IN THE CONGO.
MASS EVACUATIONS ARE UNDERWAY
THE VOLCANO THAT ERUPTED
SATURDAY KILLED DOZENS OF PEOPLE
AND COULD ERUPT AGAIN AT ANY
MOMENT.
THERE'S ALSO THE THREAT OF GAS
EXPLODING UNDERNEATH A NEARBY
LAKE.
SCIENTISTS CALL THE DISASTER
UNPRECEDENTED.
LARRY HAS BEEN COVERING THE
DISASTER AND FILED THIS REPORT.
>> Reporter: PANIC AS PEOPLE
FLEE AN UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION.
RESIDENTS OF TEN NEIGHBORHOODS
EVACUATED HOMES WITH ONLY WITH
WHAT THEIR CAN CARRY.
ESSENTIAL ITEMS AND LITTLE ELSE.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS HIT THE
ROAD ON THURSDAY, ACCORDING TO
AID AGENCIES IT'S A REALITY
FACING THIS PART OF CONGO.
THE ERUPTION ON SATURDAY PUTS
THEM IN THE HIGH-RISK OF LAVA
FLOW OR IMPLOSION FROM MAG MA
UNDERGROUND AND EARTHQUAKES HAVE
LED TO FEAR OF A SECOND
ERUPTION.
>> THIS IS A SCRAMABLE TO LEAVE
THE DANGER ZONE.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE USING EVERY
MODE OF TRANSPORTATION AVAILABLE
TO GET TO THE SAFETY ZONE.
WE'RE AGBOUT EIGHT MILES OUT AN
TRAFFIC IS BACKED UP.
THEY PROJECT UP TO 280,000
CHILDREN COULD BE DISPLACED IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE ERUPTION.
THIS MOTHER LEFT EVERYTHING
BEHIND EXCEPT HER KIDS.
IT'S ALL IN THE HANDS OF GOD,
SHE SAYS.
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS THE PRIORITY
IS PRESERVATION OF HUMAN LIFE.
BUT THE CROWDED EVACUATION ROUTE
LEADS TO SMALL TOWNS THAT ARE
HARDLY PREPARED FOR DISPLACED
PEOPLE.
SHE PREPARES A SMALL DINNER FOR
HER CHILDREN, BUT WORRIES ABOUT
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL WILL COME
FROM.
PZ.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO
TAKE CARE OF OURSELF.
WE ARE SUFFERING TOO MUCH.
>> THE LATEST ERUPTION THAT ILL
CANNED DOZENS AND DISPLACED TENS
OF THOUSANDS PUTS INDESCRIBABLE
STRESS ON A WORN DOWN
POPULATION.
THE REFUGEE COUNCIL, A LEADING
HUMANITARIAN ORGANIZATION, SAYS
IT'S THE MOST NEGLECTED
DISPLACEMENT CRISIS IN 2020.
>> IT HAS THE RICHEST MINERAL
BASE, BUT THE PEOPLE LIVING ON
TOP OF THIS MINERAL RESERVOIR
ARE AMONG THE POOREST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD AND THE MOST NET G
T
GLEGTED.
>> Reporter: THE CITY EMPTIED
INTO THE NIGHT AS PANIC SPREAD.
MANY SLEPT ROUGH ON THE STREETS.
ANXIOUS ABOUT A POTENTIAL
DISASTER.
>> LARRY IS JUST OUTSIDE THE
CITY AND HE JOINS US NOW.
WHERE ARE PEOPLE GOING?
>> Reporter: PEOPLE ARE BEING
SENT EAST TO SAKI.
BUT THERE'S NO PLAN FOR THEM.
THERE'S NO CAMP.
THERE'S NOWHERE TO HOLD ALL
THESE MOMENT WHO ARE GOING
THERE.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TELLING US
ABOUT 400,000 PEOPLE HAVE LEFT
THE CITY INTO SOME OF THEM TO
SAKI AND OTHERS.
WE'RE STANDING ON THE FOOT OF
THE MOUNT OF WHAT LED TO THE
ENTIRE CRISIS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME SMOKE
COMING OUT OF THE CRATER GAGAIN.
THE LOCAL GOVERNOR SAID THE
CRATER APPEARS TO BE EXPANDING.
THAT'S ONE DANGER.
ANOTHER ERUPTION.
THE SECOND ONE IS WHAT YOU SEE
HERE.
THIS IS THE LAVA THAT'S SEEPED
THROUGH THE WOODED AREA.
IT'S STILL IN A STATE WHERE SOME
OF IT IS STILL DANGEROUS.
IT BREAKS LIKE CHARCOAL.
IT FEELS LIKE CHARCOAL, BUT THE
SEISMIC ACTIVITY THAT'S BEEN
OBSERVED FROM THE OBSERVATORY
SAYS THE MAG MA UNDERNEATH, IT
COULD IMPLODE WITHOUT WARNING.
SO THAT COVERS PARTS OF THE
CITY, BUT ALSO THE NEIGHBORING
LAKE, THAT'S WHY THEY FWAIF THIS
MANDATORY BUT PREVENTIVE ORDER
FOR PEOPLE TO EVACUATE BECAUSE
THEY ARE AFRAID IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED WITHOUT WARNING LIKE
THE ERUPTION ON SATURDAY,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WOULD BE IN THE DIRECT PATH OF
THIS MOST ACTIVE AND DANGEROUS
VOLUCANOS IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
IF YOU LOOK TO THIS OTHER SIDE,
THIS USED TO BE A MAJOR HIGHWAY
CONNECTING TWO MAIN PROVINCES IN
THE EASTERN DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC
OF CONGO.
THAT GOT WIPED OUT ENTIRELY.
IT LOOKS LIKE EVEN THOUGH THERE
WAS.
THAT'S A DANGER.
THAT'S WHY THE GOVERNMENT IS
TRYING TO GET PAEM OUT OF HARM'S
WAY AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> SO YOU SPOKE TO THEM IN THE
PAST COUPLE DAYS.
YOU MADE SOME UNDERLYING JUST
HOW DIFFICULT, DANGEROUS THINGS
ARE FOR PEOPLE IN THE REGION.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION HERE AT
THIS POINT?
CLEARLY, THIS IS A VERY SHORT
TERM ISSUE.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING DISPLACED AS
A RESULT.
WHAT'S THE LONG-TERM SOLUTION
HERE?
>> SO THAT'S A COMPLICATED
QUESTION BECAUSE THERE'S NO
SIMPLE ANSWER FOR IT.
PART OF IT THIS EASTERN PART
ALREADY HAS A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
ARMED CONFLICT, DISEASE
OUTBREAKS, THERE'S JUST SO MUCH
SUFFERING ALREADY IN THIS PART
OF THE WORLD.
THE DISPLACEMENT CRISIS IS 6,000
PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
THAT'S WHAT THE REFUGEE COUNCIL
SAYS IS THE MOST NEGLECTED IN
THE WORLD.
ON TOP OF THAT, THEY LIVE IN THE
PATH OF AN ACTIVE VOLCANO THAT
COULD ERUPT AT ANY TIME.
THERE'S STILL 40 PEOPLE MISSING
FROM THE LAST ERUPTION.
THERE ARE 280,000 CHILDREN WHO
RISK GETTING DISPLACED IF IT
ERUPTS AGAIN.
THERE ARE 80,000 HOMES THAT HAVE
HAD TO LEAVE BECAUSE OF THIS
IMPENDING DANGER.
SOME SAY THEY NEED TO MOVE THE
CITY FURTHER AWAY.
THERE USED TO BE A WARNING
SYSTEM.
BUT IT LOST FUNDING SO THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO DO REGULAR CHECKS
AND WORN PEOPLE IN ADVANCE.
SO IF YOU WALK AROUND THE CITY,
THERE ARE FLAGS TO INDICATE THE
ALERT LEVEL.
IT'S BEEN RED SINCE THE
ERUPTION.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
THEX ONE COULD BE COMING.
>> LARRY, I